so i'm going to talk about streaming
first and then i'll talk about
streaming with signalr streaming with
web api and streaming with grpc
but we have to start with what streaming
is and what streaming isn't
and for that
we're going to open up a console window
and i'm going to demonstrate
what streaming is
it let me here's a spoiler alert it
doesn't have anything to do
with
system.io
system.iostream system.io memory stream
network stream that's
that's not streaming those are tools in
the.net framework
uh that will help you do things
maybe maybe streaming maybe not but it
they have nothing to do with what
streaming is
yeah okay
toolbox is empty yeah all right so i
might be doing a little cutting and
pasting here
so this is a document that i have um
that was adopted from
a blazer train talk that i did
i'll show you what blazer train is
it's basically a youtube show that i've
been doing for the last couple of years
and
this code
signalr
here we go signalr advanced signalr
signalr streaming episode 66
there's a link there to download the
code
and that has everything that i'm going
to show you right here
but we're going to start with this
little console application
okay
so this is a very we're going to start
off very simply
with a console application
that calls this method get messages
i hope you can all see that
you can bump it up
control plus doesn't want to work either
so we're calling this get messages right
get messages is going to return an i
enumerable of message
and message is a simple class that has a
text string property
so we're going to use
a loop
and we're going to create three messages
the text being hello whatever the number
is 0 1 2.
we're going to add those to a list of
messages and return that list
yep this is the best way to start at
nine o'clock in the morning we're going
to ease into this
first i'll just show the the app running
and then we will
walk through it and this will be our
base class and you can see that right
hello hello one hello to done
so if we if we put a breakpoint here
run this again
you should be able to do this in your
mind by now i'm going to press f11
create the new
list of messages
iterate
yes
add one
add two
add three
and return
and then we iterate again
to show the messages in the console one
two three
okay
so streaming started
uh in dot net
200 we had this ability to instead of
creating a list and returning the list
we could just say
yield
return message
instead of going and waiting for them
all to
happen
so the first thing i'll do is yep we'll
we'll do this again
now i'm going to press f11
which in visual studio will step into
get messages right
but
it does not
it skips right over that because the
compiler is smart enough to know hey
this get messages is doing a yield
return
so instead
we iterate once
so here we go
messages i get the first one
i wasn't doing f11
so f11
we get the second one
we go back
for the third one
and now we have them all
see the difference
so there's we're skipping in a level of
iteration here and that's the really
important thing
because i mean you think about it you're
when you create the data
you put it into a list you return the
list you go back you iterate through
that list again
so this way
there's one iteration
where we're calling it we get
one at a time
and that's what streaming is
and it's been in c-sharp since
since dot net 2.
so there's a new
kid in town
in c sharp 8
called async streaming
that's what i just did here
and this code
uses a new
async
i async enumerable type
all right so let's start at the top here
so h async streaming uses the iterator
pattern yield return
with
async
so before this before c-sharp 8
you could not have a get messages that
was async that did yield return
all right so without iasync innumerable
you can't do this
you can't do the iterator pattern with
async so that's the goodness that comes
in c sharp 8.
so because it's a sync your ui can start
working with the data as soon as it gets
the first piece of it
and
the benefit is perceived performance
because the user sees the first pieces
of data first
and if you have a large set to show the
user
they're going to see whatever they need
to see right away
and they're not waiting for a big list
to come
right so that's the goodness here
it's a pull operation and not a push
we've had signal our streaming for a
while using the channels
and i'm going to show you that but
that's a push operation
so async streaming is a pull
we're asking for the data we're getting
the data
this is a key right here it's not about
performance async streaming
it's not in fact your performance may
degrade
it's about perceived performance and
scalability
that's what we're after here
so now instead of
doing for each we're doing await for
each
a wait for each
var message in get messages get messages
is that same method
but
now it's using an i asynch enumerable of
message
so iasync innumerable
is not a task
because you know in async world we use
tasks
it's a value task
and value tasks
without going too far into the tech
a value task should be used whenever you
want to return a lot of something
every time you create a task you're
using uh memory
in gen 1 in the gen 1 memory space
and so those have to be deallocated
but with a value task it's much more
lightweight and doesn't create any gen 1
allocations
so iasync innumerable
you can think of it as
you don't have to say task of i sync
your numerable because it is a task it's
a value task
so the signature is simply async
i think innumerable
of whatever you're returning
and then inside you do a yield return
and that's that's it
so
let's
let's walk through this
we'll start right here
all right f11 f11
right
just have something async in here
get our first message
yield return
back in the client
show it
next message
etc
so a console app doesn't you know really
show off
uh you know this thing so what we're
really going to do is show you how to
use this
idea use this iasync enumerable
to return signalr data
to return
web api data and
the same data from grpc
okay so
i'm starting
with a blazer server application
called server
signalr streaming demo
still don't know what happened to my
toolbox
okay
no problem
[Music]
and signalr streaming demo
is going to need
a signalr client
this is the blazer server app so it's
going to be pretty easy to demo
all right so
we need the asp.net core signal our
client library because even though
signalr is built into asp.net core it's
just the server side that's built in
if we want to act as a client to call
into a signalr hub we need this
and next
you gotta make some changes to
program cs
i've got some global usings in there
which are my new best
friend our signalr
client
we're calling
add signalr right there
and with response compression just so
that we can get as much performance out
of this as possible
and then we map
the hub stream hub which i haven't done
yet to slash stream hub so let's add
that
so signalr streaming has been around
for a while but it's been sort of a
they had to invent a new mechanism to do
this so they're using the channel
mechanism signalr channels
and um
well you'll see the difference i think
the the new way is much cleaner
here's our stream hub
so if you're not familiar with signalr
hubs
what this does is it acts as a sort of a
single point
a single server if you will that clients
can call into
and the magic of the hub is that it can
then turn around and send messages to
every other client that's connected to
it
you could send messages to all clients
including the sender
you could just send a message back to
the sender
you could send a message to all others
in other words sort of a broadcast to
every other client
and also if you have the connection id
of a particular client you could just
send a private message to that
user
and it uses web sockets under the hood
so all port 80 all very easy to use
there's no configuration
and the clients can be anywhere
you could have javascript clients you'd
have c-sharp clients on any platform
um any type of application mobile
web you got you name it
all right so we'll come back to the hub
here
and i'll explain the code
um
yeah so we're going to use channels
here and this is just sort of
explaining things
all right
so blazer code
so this goes into imports razer so that
we can access it from
our index page
and then here we go
change index
wait for everything to wake up
and yeah i guess i can start with this
code right here so uninitialized async
happens first
and what we're doing here is we're
creating the connection
with an absolute url
since it's all one application it's no
big deal stream hub
we start the hub
and then
we have our handlers for messages
so this one handles the message receive
channel stream data
and i've got a a field here called
receive channel message
and um invoking state has changed
and another one receive async stream
data
this one is the channel version this is
the async version but they do
uh exactly the same thing
we'll get to those in a second
and what i guess i'm going to do is just
run this
to show you what it does
i think that makes it easier when you're
looking at the code to sort of
understand what you've seen
first
and i'm going to create two windows here
okay
so we're using the two methods that
signal our does streaming one is a push
and one is a pull this one's a push the
get channel stream
and we're just
receiving ten numbers and then stopping
and the same over here and these are
completely independent of each other
the async stream works the same way
uh it does the same thing but it does it
with less code and then we also have the
ability in signalr to stream
from a client to to the hub and then the
hub can turn around and push out the
data to everyone else
so that's what we're doing here
one is using channels
and the other is using
async
okay
but they're doing the same thing i don't
know if you can see but
the these are fields are updating once a
second
so basically we're streaming to the hub
the hub turns around and sends data to
everyone else
all right
let's look at the hub first
this is using channels and channels are
as i said before the the old way to do
streaming in signalr
this is a method called get channel
stream where we pass in a count and a
delay how many times do we want to you
know create a number and what's the
delay between them and a cancellation
token
which you can use to stop things
the first thing we're doing is creating
a bounded channel
and again this is all old stuff you
probably will never if you've never done
it by now you probably won't you'll be
using the async i just want to show you
the difference
a bounded channel has a limit
so we're saying this is a channel that
we're going to send 10 items
and it's event so 10 integers okay
um and then we're calling this write
items async and returning the reader
so write items async does the work
and we just have a loop
and we're calling writer.writeasync
that number and then delaying with the
weight task delay
right so we're pushing data out
to
the client
now in contrast
let's look at
the i sink enumerable
right
we're now we're using
c sharp eight i async enumerable
and here we've got our count
and we're yield returning the number
and delay so all in one
small
set of code
and again it's a pull it's a pull
operation not a push operation so the
client is in control of this just like
when we did the console app
and we called get messages and yield
return returns the data it's the same
exact thing except we've got
you know the internet between us now
okay
uh so going to
index razor
let's go
up here and we've got our get channel
stream
for the first button
let's look at what that looks like
all right so we've got a
our channel message and the button text
because we're going to stop it
so let's make sure we have a connection
and then
we create a channel from the hub
right specifying we want to receive 10
consecutive events exactly 500
milliseconds apart
so this is actually calling
stream as channel async on the hub
and that gives us a channel
and then we wait because the channel is
pushing to us
we're waiting to read
and then we do a try read and if we get
some data
we're going to say hey we receive this
data and update
okay
now in contrast
here's the get async stream
we're going to connect we're going to
return a stream
from the hub
yep and so that's an iesync enumerable
of int
and then we're just awaiting for each
receiving the data
and calling state has changed
a lot more simple
to go down to the
sending you know streaming channels from
client to server let's go there
so we're creating the channel this is an
unbounded channel
because we're not going to stop until
the user stops
right so it's unbounded doesn't have a
limit
and it's with strings so we're going to
say upload stream to channel
and we also need a sort of a flag to so
that the user can set it to tell us to
stop
right like a cancellation token but
different
and so when we set that
we're going to stop so
just going through a loop here
and using the writer
the channel writer to write async
pushing to the server right
in contrast when we stream
to the service
to the server
we're calling
send async upload stream and we're
passing as an argument
client stream data which guess what
that's our isync enumerable
and that is going to use you guessed it
yield return
all right so that's enough signalr i
think you get it
that uh this is what streaming
does but the really dramatic
result will be
when we show
uh using web api and grpc
so i've got this existing demo that i
wrote
when
i was testing grpc and the performance
versus web api
and i'll start with that
and what it does is i created this dummy
data set of
5 000 person objects you know with a
couple of fields in there
just with you know like
the latin word generator kind of thing
just so that we have some data
and then i tested it with web api
and using grpc now grpc
started as a a way to do remote
procedure calls in a for web services
i'm sorry for micro services
and you know first server to server kind
of thing because it's what is the
fastest way i can communicate
from this guy over to that guy
and it started at google
but if you look up grpc on the web
and there's a section what does it stand
for
it's a it stands for
grpc remote procedure calls so it's
yeah okay but we know it used to stand
for google right
but google doesn't own it
um
so it's uh it's completely open source
and it's completely cross-platform
and so what they did is they created
this language that was sort of platform
agnostic
and a platform agnostic way to define
uh classes or messages they call them
and services
and so then it's up to each platform
to do code generation to implement
those classes
however the platform does and the
services that are used to do the
communication
so i'll show you
one more time i'll show you the code
work running
and then we'll go dissect it and you can
understand it so remember this one
started just as a way to
test the performance of
grpc versus web api
so i simply have a website
that
uh
downloads these 5 000 records using each
method and then you know measures the
performance
so this one is the api
now
here's the thing we're probably not
going to be
going to get 5000 records
for our users right
raise your hand repeat after me i will
not
give the user 5 000 records yeah okay
so um
but it's a good test
so the second time i don't know if you
can see that but it's 18
uh 1824 milliseconds or 1.8 seconds
the first time it was two something for
the api
so you just have to you know it's
compiling and all that stuff it's always
going to be faster the second time grpc
whoa
515 milliseconds the second time
331 milliseconds now you're thinking hey
maybe i can return 5000 records
to my user if that's what they want and
they pay me for it
and then i also just have a demo to get
a random person with grpc
um so that is performance
but let's talk about streaming
so
the first of all let me just show you
what the data is here
we have our
person class which i don't actually have
because when you use grpc
it gets generated for you
so in grpc
you've got
a person message
right here
so we've got an int id we've got a
string first name a last name a bio and
a photo url
so when you use this it behind the
scenes will create the person class and
this is one of the
issues with using grpc is where do my ma
i can't where are my models right
you can only have one
model called person
so this is generating it and you don't
really see it anymore
all right
um also notice the numbers id equals one
first name equals two last name equals
three it was because grpc uses a binary
serialization protocol
and it's really tight and it does things
by ordinal by position it doesn't know
names of things doesn't like json it
doesn't have the names and the strings
and things in there
it's all by ordinal
and for every grpc request
every every service endpoint which is
defined here with the service keyword
um you've got
one request
message type and one reply message type
always
there aren't
it's not as flexible as say web api
but that's it so we have a get all and
we have a get person by id
so get all people request is defined as
an empty
message an empty class
it doesn't matter if you're not going to
send anything you still have to make an
empty class
if you're even if there are no arguments
so this is the proto file in grpc that
is for the
service
now here's the people service
itself
which was generated
by
grpc web
and
grpc web is a sort of an http version of
grpc
so it wasn't until grpc web came around
for net that we could use this in a
client
to call into a service so that's that's
what i'm using here grpc web
uh and so remember this is all generated
i didn't have to um oh wait a second no
people service wasn't generated you had
you do have to implement this but it has
to be based on
people base
and all these methods are virtual so
you're overriding the methods
okay
so that's what we're doing here now
compare this with the person's
controller
in web api
and in both of these i'm using a
person's manager which i created
and get all we're just returning
persons manager people
so the person's manager
just wraps around that people.json file
and just returns the whole the whole
thing as a list
very very simple
uh on the client side i've got an api
service for calling the web api
and here's my get all you've probably
seen this and done this a million times
but there it is
get a sync persons
deserialize it
to a list of person
but i'm calling the the code for
uh
for grpc directly
so what i'm doing here in index
you know my page
is i'm injecting the api service so i
can call the api
and i'm injecting the people client
which gets generated for me
by grpc
so
test
api
we create
we we save the date time
right as start time we call get all
and then we calculate the elapsed time
and we have our results
which is just a string
that says
this many records returned in this many
milliseconds
the grpc
is pretty similar except we're calling
peopleclient.c
with a new get all people request which
has nothing in it remember
and then if that list is null
we do the same thing we just test it
all right so that is the code as it is
let's add some streaming
to it
and all this blah blah blah is what i
just went over
all right here we go
so we're looking at the protofile yeah
this is the class that gets created
uh so here we go we're going to add
to the person's controller on the api
side
and async
stream
endpoint
guess what this is going to look like
i sink enumerable
right
couldn't be easier
in web api
so we're getting all the people
and we're yield returning them one at a
time
so now here's the
service call
from api service
on the client
it's going to look like this
and yep this is a little weird because
i don't think that the the json tools
have caught up yet
for all the streaming this is what i had
to do with newtonsoft json
i created a json serializer
so i get my
stream from getstream async and you know
i guess i lied
i do use system i o stream in here but
you get the idea right it's not that's
not what streaming is
this is just to return some data
so now i'm creating a stream reader
from that stream
and now because
json
uh treats a json string as a series of
tokens which are read one at a time
and there's uh two tokens that i have to
ignore start array and end array before
i can deserialize
and so that's what we're doing
and we're just getting one person at a
time
deserializing that without the start and
end array tokens
okay
now over to grpc
oh and we're going to replace the
contents of index razor yeah let's do
that
new demo
and we'll come back to you
okay
so
on the grpc side
we go to the proto file
where this where the service is defined
and we're adding a new remote procedure
call
called get all stream
and this time instead of returning a
people reply
which has the which is essentially an
array right repeated
is the generic protobuf
word that defines an array
or a collection
um
we're returning stream
of
person all right so this is the the
generic grpc way to say hey we want to
return a stream
and then
yep we add this to people service
because now
when we compile we've got a new virtual
method in people service that we can
override
that's the controller
here's people service
okay
so this is
uh get all stream
takes an all people request
and returns an iserver stream writer of
person
so under the hood this is all i think
innumerable
but it's
wrapped up in grpc speak
so you have a response stream
and the server context
you can use if you want to we're not
using it here
and then we're writing to the response
stream which does the rest
that does all the
yield returning and all of that
and then
so this is looking at the code i think
that's it yeah all right let's run it
so this demo is a little bit different
we're going to start with
the performance aspect of retrieving
5000 records via a standard api call
versus an api stream
and via standard grpc call versus a grpc
stream
and hopefully this will sort of cement
in that it isn't about performance
right it's about
scalability
so here's the api again this is the same
as we had before
2.4 seconds the second time would be
1.8 seconds
now the same thing as a stream
all right 2.1 seconds
and
2 seconds
so it's taking longer to retrieve all of
them with the stream
okay
this the grpc side is really dramatic
look at this 508 milliseconds 314
milliseconds but as a stream
a whole second
almost a second so there's a three times
performance degradation just to get the
entire set
with a stream
all right but that's not what it's all
about so here's
the money shot right here
uh and that is we're going to use
counter the counter page
to
actually show
the ui
with the data as it's coming in
and i i mean i could go through the code
and show you the code but it's really
simple
because i have encounter i have a list a
select an html select
that shows only the first 20
records
okay
what we're going to do is start the
timer start streaming
get the first 20 and after the first 20
i'm going to update the ui i'm going to
call
data's changed in blazer which is going
to refresh
and we're going to continue every 100
records
to update the ui to say we've got
another 100 records
right and as we're getting them you're
going to see
the list well you won't see the list
grow but you'll see the scroll bar
gets smaller
right
so let's just do the api stream first
okay 670 milliseconds to get the first
20.
all right let's do it again in fact
let's clear this
come back and do it again
that time only 57 milliseconds to get
the first 20. and look i can scroll down
and as i'm scrolling they're still
coming in
right
all right now grpc
189 milliseconds to get the first 20.
all right
so the to the user they just said wow i
just downloaded 5 000 records and by the
time they move their mouse over to start
scrolling they're already there
right
perceived performance
let's try it again
34 milliseconds to get the first 20
after it's been compiled once
so that shows
the power of of streaming right there
grpc is more performant than web api
number one and number two when you use
it with streaming
uh it's the the performance really
shines and especially you know for the
user
so questions
yeah
well in place of one yeah
yeah that's a great question
as a matter of fact
i don't even know if this um
is
still working
but
uh on my github repo
i wrote a grpc generator
let's see if it's on blazer train
um i wrote a grpc generator now grpc is
in of itself a generator but what
happens if you have
all these classes already set up right
yeah generate your grpc layer so check
out episode 46
of
of blazer train
and the code okay yeah it is
downloading a zip file but i i also have
that
on github somewhere
so yeah generate your grpc layer episode
and essentially the idea is that if you
have
already have classes you already have a
web api
and you've got a large
you know
code base
how do i convert that over to porto
proto files i said porto files isn't
that neat i don't even think of that
proto files and services and that's what
i attempted to do with this uh
with this grpc generator
great question anyone else
right
yeah
uh i don't because they they do the same
thing just in a different way
if if you need the the push
feature of a channel for any reason i
guess that's one way to one reason but
they do the same thing at the end of the
day
but i don't have i never use the channel
in production
so
i i can't i don't have that perspective
that someone else might have
but the only difference really is that
channel is a push async is a pull
and for if for any reason you need the
push architecture
yeah
other questions
yes sir
yeah
yes yeah you have the same level of
security in grpc
uh that you have in web api
yep
absolutely uh and you know there's a guy
here who knows
more about grpc and its internal
workings than i do and that's mark
rundle
so yeah because he basically built
uh a wcf to grpc
a converter i think it's either a
converter or if it's a code generator or
something like that but
anybody who has a large array of wcf
services
he's
figured out how to move those over to
grpc
others
coffee time
all right thank you very much